look at that
look at that look at that look at that
that is
smarter than you what who thinks he's
smarter than you what you think you're
smarter than you
look at that look at that look at that
Pac-Man's a loser Pac-Man's a loser
Pac-Man's a loser at man's a loser
like that
look at that Alex Jones is lying to you
that might come as a shot
this is
fake colors Jones has fake callers Jones
has fake callers Jones has fake color
this is
a corporate takeover censorship
demanding arrest tyranny
look at that corporate takeover
censorship debanking arrest tyranny
look at that look at that corporate tank
over censorship demanding a rash tyranny
look at that
the loser Pac-Man's a loser he's a
description he's a disgrace
and these are the scratch and he's a
disgrace look at that look at that look
at that look at that
well it's a very special day because we
have today returning to the program Mike
Lindell CEO and inventor of my pillow
what
what would you like me to say David
I'm not a lawyer the lawyers are lawyers
what's so hard to understand
I'm
up everything
they can pull these names it's just like
every state every state has people that
voted that don't live in the states hold
it David you're doing the population of
Wisconsin I have a moral compass who
million you can get them I did I got
requests out to every single these are
right are the voter rolls David you're
not listening
[Music]
get rid of my espresso machine the
voting machine David everything that can
be packed you got you know credit cards
companies get hacked businesses act gas
companies act who did this attack who
did this Cyber attack that's all I'm
about we can't have computers running
our election Mike you've mentioned so
much let me just make one comment here
nope nope nope melt them down and turn
them into prison bars
[Music]
when you have a computer you can change
one number you can do anything you hack
in and you can expect Millions where if
you had to do the same thing with paper
you'd have to have a ball of people you
asked me a dumb question about getting
rid of machines if you want to be a
humorous interview get rid of my
espresso machine give me a break
[Music]
um what what I'm not a lawyer the
lawyers are lawyers
I'm not a lawyer the lawyers are lawyers
[Music]
you should have one of my pillows too
it goes
mangoes
I love mangoes too
now that we are up under our body's
regime my bag of mangoes now costs
[Music]
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
a bag of mangoes mango art mangoes like
a three box seat that's it eight or
eleven bucks
[Music]
fingers
the Wisconsin crowd identified with the
mango
affected
don't want me to me
it's highway robbery is what you doing
[Music]
Donald Trump killed Donald Trump I love
Donald Trump but no more dropped by if
the drop boxes are just so bad no more
drop boxes Dickinson hologic and
cephahide
that was about a guy named a rhino named
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney
real Beauty had to give the American
people their voice back by building
something called truth truth essential
he voted against Kate's law and he voted
for Obama
you know we've endorsed Dr Oz we've
endorsed
JP Greg JD Mandel and he's doing great
I've had more investigations and Jesse
James Billy the could some of the
world's greatest cricket players
as the great religious teacher Swami
Vive come
once said
I hope they now go and take a look at
the oranges or the oranges of the uh uh
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation and God bless
the United States thank you very much he
was awarded the broad star and the
combat infantry and badge for his
service we have to keep our country gate
but it's not I mean for some reason it's
just not great anymore if you care about
Law and Order look Law and Order in
normal times roughly 40 percent of fresh
vegetables at about 40 percent China
nambia's health system is increasingly
self-sufficient this is not about virtue
cycling and signing and the great
General and President
Ulysses S Grant he's done he's really
come back a long way over the last 10
years hasn't he
appreciate it very much Tim Apple when
they gaze upon your semites your
seminites towering Sequoias they
delivered a swept and swept in you know
that sweeping it was Swift and it was
sweeping like nobody's
ever seen anything happen units of
plasma for plasma donate plasmid into
failing New York Times by
Anonymous really an anonymous gutless
coward I may ask Marilyn Lockheed
the leading
woman's business who teaches should ever
be allowed to teach transgender to our
children while they're parent of
themselves
no nobody has to have parental consent
and we will totally oppose the Biden
administration at this this
Administration he made some statements
rough statements on Jewish you heard
them and you know them well well welcome
everybody no rough statements on Jewish
expected out of my mouth today that I
can promise you uh Donald dump I can't
speak for but we are standing by in New
Hampshire I know that it feels like it
still barely past the 2020 election
part of the reason it feels that way is
because the right won't stop talking
about it but uh it is actually 2024
election we are in the heat of it we are
in the heat of it we are almost think of
it we're almost halfway through 2023.
and the first Republican primary debate
has been scheduled for August of this
year I don't know what day yet but
sometime in August it's going to be I
believe in Milwaukee and Trump is
already saying he might not go I mean
you know whether it will be really be a
debate or not we don't know
um but quite frankly we really are in
the thick and in the wide of the 2024
presidential election President Joe
Biden has announced he will be running
for re-election much speculation one way
and the other will he run won't he run
he is running Nikki Haley recently
saying Biden would be 82 at the start of
his second term that's true and that she
doesn't think it's likely that Trump I'm
sorry that Biden would make it to 86.
she believes it's likely that Biden
would die during his second term
um statistically that's not true we have
the Social Security Actuarial tables and
an 82 year old man in the United States
in 2022 has a life expectancy of 6.8
years so aside from whether this is even
a really good argument to vote for Nikki
Haley which I you know you could be like
Biden's gonna die next month I'm still
not voting for Nikki Haley she's
completely out of her mind she's also
wrong on the math which is a very
popular way for Republicans to be wrong
they're wrong in spirit and they're
wrong in fact uh but next week I'm
probably as a non-biden cheerleader you
all know that I'm not a Biden
cheerleader oh here's Marjorie Taylor
Green's boyfriend
um as a non-biden cheerleader
as I look at it on paper and on uh
screen and on newsprint and on fax
machine as I look at it the record of
Biden
it's really hard to argue that the guy
doesn't have what is pointing towards
one of the most successful first terms
by virtue of the number of
accomplishments of any recent president
it's not like I was looking to present
that to you with some kind of Swift and
swooping
um excitement
but it really looks that way when I
examine the record so we're going to do
that next week today we are in
Manchester New Hampshire Donald Trump
expected 19 minutes from now
I don't know if it will be his standard
grievances about how he won in 2020 and
how Hunter Biden's a criminal and how
Joe Biden's a criminal and how Barack
Obama is a criminal and how Hillary
Clinton's a criminal and how the left
are criminals and how everybody's got I
don't know if it'll be the standard list
of grievances
or whether Trump might present you know
maybe observations about the importance
of diplomatic soft power
um during the Cold War you know maybe
Trump will give a historical speech of
some kind and talk about history or
maybe Trump will relate uh to us the
story of Argentinian currency
devaluation in the broader context of uh
international monetary fund loans you
know maybe that's what Trump will talk
about today or maybe he'll just stand up
and attack trans people
I don't know I guess we'll have to wait
and see let's look at a couple of super
chats that are coming in and see what is
on people's minds by the way absolutely
no need to adjust your screens in any
way I know people are saying David the
stream just started how are we already
at 21 we're actually thanks to Daniel
tomek at 22 already we have two ways of
filling the bar tonight you can sign up
at joinpakman.com
or you can become a twitch subscriber
both are very very much welcome
uh koyani five cat five I uh getting a
twitch Prime subscription and saying
maybe we'll get the snake poem I don't
think Trump's gonna do the snake poem
today
I don't think so all right super chats
David sir I write with tears in my eyes
what are the status of the mango prices
I thought the woke mobber antifa brought
the mango prices up listen I'm gonna
I've already admitted to this previously
I've basically shifted 99 to Frozen
mango and the truth about mango is mango
is a complicated fruit mango
you you get a mango right and you watch
it you watch it you watch it like a pot
of water that you're trying to boil
and it's not ripe it's not ripe it's not
ripe I go away for one night I come back
home it's over ripe and half of the
mango ends up in the trash or being
flushed down the toilet so I admit it I
have switched over to Frozen mango it's
perfectly ripe it tastes fine and I know
it's not you know the epitome it's not
it's not the climax of Afghani mangoes
that you can get for like a seven day
period I get that okay but it's good
enough for me and so that's where we're
at as far as mangoes go Will trump make
any rough statements on woke today yes
Trump will attack wokeness during
today's speech I am sure of it
that's one tuck one no tuck absolutely
Seinfeld reference you've got to love it
uh hoping for an audio glitch oh yeah
let's see if I have any audio glitches
here further scream that
Trump this is
I always am hoping that antifa has been
put in charge of the audio at Trump's
events
um and we will we will see that very
very soon I'm sure do I am I having the
mango on its own no usually with my
breakfast I have a beautiful fruit salad
and it's usually mango
wild blueberries you're not gonna catch
me with these domesticated blueberries
that have had all of the will to live
knocked out of them right you know like
a domesticated cougar I'm having wild
blueberries mango
uh either Blackberry or raspberry
and then based on what's what's around
and what's fresh either a banana or a
kiwi and then sometimes I'll even
sprinkle unsweetened
because they'll pry you're not going to
catch me with sweetened coconut flake
okay it's not gonna happen here uh
unsweetened uh coconut flake on top of
the fruit salad I have it as a side to
whatever I'm having for breakfast
um on wild unadulterated they're
essentially a feral blueberries is what
I have uh it's pretty pretty remarkable
stuff I will say all right Jody says
David is a Canadian in England I've been
watching you since 2015. it's weird to
be so invested in U.S politics it's been
pretty gross gross but appreciated thank
you you know what's interesting Jody I
was just in the United Kingdom and as I
I told this story uh was it on the bonus
I guess it was on the bonus show
um about how so many
would it be Britain's is that the
appropriate Britain's bro b-r-i-t-o-n-s
approached me not crying or anything
like that this is a real story seven
seven different groups of people
sometimes it was a couple for example
approached me when I was in England and
said they watched the show
uh one guy actually said what the f are
you doing in my country but he was
saying it in India he wasn't like get
out he was like surprised like what the
are you doing here
um at the bath train station in fact and
they said we're we're just so obsessed
with American politics because it's such
a mess so not a unique situation Jody
great to hear from you
uh is New Hampshire the south of the
north New Hampshire feels like a social
political outlier on many lists
education gun laws voter restrictions
anti-trans BS Etc New Hampshire is an
odd place for sure
New Hampshire is an odd place for sure I
uh you know growing up I I was more
partial to Vermont than New Hampshire
David sir will you now admit that Trump
is a foregone conclusion to win the
Republican primary he won't go to jail
and won't drop out of the race so here's
my my uh analysis on this
if nothing changes Trump is going to be
the Republican nominee
if nothing changes
and I've been putting forth a number of
similar analyzes on the program recently
uh thank you to Desiree DeLong
Desiree just gifted a subscription at
joinpakman.com also big thank you to
McKinley P for the twitch Prime
subscription and to duck Co for the
twitch Prime subscription putting us at
26. folks the coupon code today two
coupon codes are available indicted
saves you a bunch of money
joinpakman.com and indicated which is
the way that Trump misspelled indicted
in his own announcement that he was
being indicted indicated saves you even
more let's take a look at a few of the
goings-on outside this Trump rally and
just sort of more generally at what is
going on uh let's see here don't know
what this is all about
Paris Hilton appeals to Chuck Schumer
all right we'll deal with that a little
bit later I wanted to see if there was
anything from outside the New Hampshire
event that we might look at uh to glean
some sense of the mood there
uh that's a Lauren bobert speech
um oh look at this
our friend Jamie Raskin
Melancholy
[Music]
um
you have Jamie Raskin unplugged
[Music]
good for Jaime Raskin Big Friend of the
show supporter of the David packman show
and it looks like uh looks like
treatment has been going well for him
and that is such a such a such a great
thing
um let's see what else we have going on
here I I thought we had some video from
outside oh let's see DeSantis melts down
outside the protective bubble of his
scripted events let's see that this I
have to see
no no and then all that's BS no totally
totally yeah
said that
how would they know me okay think about
that do you honestly believe that's
credible so this is 22006 I'm a junior
officer do you honestly think that they
would have remembered me from Adam of
course not they're just trying to get
into the news because they know people
like you will consume it because it fits
your pre-ordained narrative that you're
trying to spend focus on the facts this
guy is seriously not ready for like the
degree to which he is not able to handle
this stuff is actually quite stunning uh
I don't I don't see him as ready for
Prime Time whatsoever what's up with his
voice his voice is like it's in the back
of the throat if I have to sort of like
my head back in order to even get
that
it's a it's a very interesting thing
it's it's in it's back here it's in the
back of the throw absolutely not
um interesting I don't know that that's
going to serve him particularly well for
the campaign if there is to be a
campaign
um all right we may not have
uh
John King is oh X John King used to be
married to Dana Bash
I had no idea about that interesting all
right I don't really care guy at Trump
rally says he doesn't believe in God but
has a Christian worldview that's
interesting let's say oh if I'm open and
honest I'm an atheist but uh I align
more closely with a Christian
conservative worldview and so uh I
pretty much support Christian
conservatism that horror that whole
moral compass and so that's what I stand
for Wow pretty confused guy huh
um interesting stuff though for sure
let's see if we have anything else from
outside the rally
there may not be I mean it quite frankly
it doesn't look like the biggest crowd
Newsmax is airing YouTubers raving about
how the channel is talking about the New
World Order
sometimes sometimes Mark conspiracy
theorist Mark Dice that I can do without
Trump putting out another one of these
stupid videos I'm just gonna skip it
we're gonna get plenty of trump
um a guy with a Melania poster board is
at the rally
we covered this tucker video on today's
podcast so I don't want to talk about it
right now but the funniest part of this
video is Tucker dressing up like he
still has a show I don't know why I find
that hilarious I imagine that he's
wearing no pants on the bottom
uh let's see new commercial during the
Trump rally broadcast the guy who
recommended Ivermectin has a new
supplement oh this I have to see protein
Spike protein is the toxic substance
that attaches to your cells to allow
mRNA to enter worse both covid and the
vaccine function by using Spike proteins
to attach to your cells many of us have
become overloaded with excess Spike
protein from our surroundings over the
past three years and haven't made the
connection last three years it's been a
long three years in between not feeling
100 and Spike protein overload this is a
sad reality that we all have to address
fortunately there is help the chief
medical board someone I know actually
had a spike protein overload next thing
I knew there was mango everywhere it was
a really weird thing to see wellness
company including Dr Peter McCullough
the doctor that recommended ivervectin
and hydroctin
oh that's genius these wreath you know
I've said it before I don't know this is
the women were here hearing from is um
hold on let's see where was she the
woman reading that ad is this woman on
the left here okay sales would have gone
up astronomic it's shocking to me that
someone with terrible diction
has a broadcast program and this isn't
about like oh she has a disability she
has a stutter it's not she just says
terrible diction and she doesn't seem to
know a lot of words you're doing an ad
based on this is the guy who recommended
Ivermectin and you mispronounce
Ivermectin we all have to address
fortunately there is help the chief
medical board at the wellness company
including Dr Peter Mccalla the doctor
that recommended ivervectin
oh God inject the Iver vecton right into
my veins and hydroxychloroquine is a
president Trump back in 2020 yeah if
there's any greater um credential than
having recommended ivervectin to prompt
dear God these people are nuts all right
thanks to you do suck as well as Harry
for the twitch Prime subscriptions
putting us at 28 I also want to say
thank you
two uh no one no no one else no uh in
all seriousness coupon code today is
indicted we are moments away from
hearing from Donald Trump and we'll look
at a couple other items here if we can
from outside the rally
guy at Trump rally I would take a bullet
for Trump a lot of us would yeah
probably not probably probably not a lie
my support
my supporter of Donald Trump is
unwavering I would take a bullet for the
man seriously and a lot of us would and
we're gonna even if they wouldn't put
him on the ballot we'd write him in okay
that's an interesting idea do the
writings thanks to weatherboxer for the
twitch Prime subscription 24 months with
weather boxer very much appreciate that
it is so cult-like here this same Guy
believes Trump was sent by God to
preserve preserve Abe Lincoln's dream
I think it's very important to support
Donald Trump if not our nation goes down
I believe he was sent by God to preserve
Abraham Lincoln's promise that at a
government of the people and by the
people of the four people will not
perish but I think it's rather ironic
because I remember probably nobody else
knows this this Armory in 1976 I was
here when I was in high school and this
here's this is where Ronald Reagan gave
his speech announcing that he was
Primary in President Ford yeah really so
and because of that we know that it's
just going to be an incredible
incredible event here with Donald Trump
a bay photo asks do you think there's a
possibility meatball Ron decides not to
run but instead tries to repair his
relationship with Trump for a VP pick I
think it is possible DeSantis doesn't
run I do not believe DeSantis has any
shot at being Trump's VP in fact I think
Trump's leaning towards a female VP at
this particular point in time could be
wrong about that as uh as with
everything Brian says via Super Chat
love the show I used to think
conservative media was the most
dangerous thing in the country but I'm
starting to wonder if it's helping Dems
because it is so over the top crazy yes
still nuts but maybe a shift yeah I mean
it the problem is it's hard to know the
balance on the one hand conservative
media radicalizes a lot of people who
who fall for it on the other hand it
also disabuses many people of even
considering voting for Republicans
because it is so insane I don't know
where the balance is on that
David sir the ATF kicked down my door my
front door to take my stove the agents
were crying hey you wanna here's a Funny
Story by the way I recently uh said
goodbye I held a funeral and burial
service for my gas stove it was just
showing its age it was time for a new
stove so I went with induction it's an
electric stove I once had an induction
stove about a year ago at another place
I lived and it was so great that I
decided I'm getting an induction stove
and it was a beautiful delivery and I
saluted and cried actually as they took
the stove and you know Joe Biden even
called and said never again will you be
allowed to have a gas stove so they took
the the gas stove the guy who delivered
the new induction stove
was proselytizing me to Christianity not
a joke folks not a joke he
um he said to me how did it even start
he started with uh
oh he saw he saw my baby daughter and
said oh uh you're you're so you're
married and I said actually I'm not
married and he said oh well you know
either way
marriage is a gift from God and I said
is it and at this point I'm like dude
hook up the freaking stove and get out
of here and uh he said yeah you know why
because in uh Matthew 64 you know some
started saying something and I just said
to him in these situations I don't say
I'm Jewish because some proselytizing
evangelicals like the Jews and they're
like oh you're gonna help us bring Jesus
then you'll die but you'll help us bring
Jesus others don't like the Jews so I
just said I'm not actually a religious
he said that's okay
God still provides marriage to everyone
um
and it got really really really awkward
now 10 years ago 10 years ago David
Pacman would have reported the guy
and tried to get him fired
now I just feel bad because I'm like
this guy probably doesn't even really
make that much money
I'm not gonna do it I'm not gonna report
it I'll just you know
never get a delivery from this company
again but it was very very
unprofessional I agree
50 super chat with uh from Tiffy Kitty
who says David sir I come to you with
tears in my eyes from laughing so hard
at the Maga cult over on Troth Central I
highly recommend the meltdowns are
Priceless it is crazy on truth it is
crazy on Truth Central it really really
is uh whoa we are seeing a massive dump
of memberships our great friend from
Tokyo Kyoko awaya just dumped in five
gifted memberships if you want a free
membership do not even think about
emailing me just go to davidpackman.com
free membership and sign up for a free
membership my request to you today is
simple and it is extraordinarily
straightforward if you find any value at
all in what we do
consider getting a membership on my
website it's so quick and it is so easy
you go to joinpakman.com
you sign up if you know how to fill out
a form on the internet that's really all
you need to know if you would like a
discount it's so easy it's criminally
cheap you use the term indicated as a
coupon sorry sorry
indicted as a coupon code and you'll get
a nice discount if you want an even
bigger discount you can use the coupon
code indicated which is how Donald Trump
misspelled indicted on his own truth
post and then the discount is even
bigger so indicted big discount
indicated even bigger discount and I
will thank everybody who signs up oh and
thanks Kyoko who just gifted one more
making many free memberships available
to people
and also thank you to boshimonos
boshimono signing up via twitch Prime
super chats keep pouring in Trump
expected right now any moment Trump is
expected hey David love the Candace
Owens David Pacman has no soul clip when
will it be added to the member sound
board that's a great question Johnny
um I actually
I don't think I have it on this
soundboard hold on that is a freaking
Predator right there damn it hold on a
second but he's gonna represent you long
and hard no
I have to add it I'm in the other studio
today I've got to get it added here
we're gonna make it happen Johnny we're
gonna make it happen
David are you actually on truth if you
are thanks for doing it for us no I mean
let me see I guess I think I have a
truth Social account but I don't think
I'm ever logged in when I'm on I never
use it
uh
uh yeah I don't know
I I guess I must have an account but I'm
never logged in
I don't you apparently you don't need
one I guess to look at stuff on truth
it's all very weird very very weird all
right let's do a couple um let's do a
couple voicemails here before we move on
because there is uh there is a lot a lot
a lot going on on the voicemail number
um let's see a lot of uh attract
detractors I guess
um
let's see here
and again let's listen to this one
hey David siren again uh because they
keep saying Cindy is closing inflation
how can we
I can say that
billion years now the economy worked
okay let me I'm going to look into that
and see what I can research let me see
Nikki Haley
Haley's like this
this is why you don't like her speeches
every sentence she says ends like this
no matter what she's saying she ends
like this
so that's why you don't find her
speeches interesting
yeah that's pretty much it okay well
that I mean that is a probably an
accurate assessment I have to say
David just wondering who's writing Nikki
Haley's speeches is it the Rosetta Stone
people or what this is one time in
America where people live and what we
need to do all right so a lot of people
not very impressed by uh
Nikki Haley's speeches
David
hair is unprofessional it's distracting
look in the mirror before you go live
comb your hair yeah so I actually got I
talk about this on the podcast today oh
thanks bionic bill for the twitch Prime
subscription really appreciate that I
got a bunch of very very nice messages
from people because on yesterday's show
I had a really weird thing sticking out
of my hair
and um people were worried some people
thought that I I like I'm I'm having an
alcohol problem which I'm not I honestly
I really don't even drink anymore at all
I never drink a lot but I like don't
drink at all anymore I've just kind of
like lost my taste for it weirdly uh
since the baby was born and I go to bed
at 10 every day
um but then some people are like you
know David sometimes when people start
uh letting their grooming fall to the
Wayside it's because something's going
on it's like depression this that or the
other thing it's quite literally that my
days are so busy that I shower 45
minutes before going to bed and my hair
is so thick it's this thick Semitic hair
it takes four hours to dry and because
of the schedule I'm going to bed with
wet hair and then it basically freezes
in a weird position and I can't get it
under control the next day that's all it
is it's not alcohol it's not drugs it's
not depression it's nothing it's nothing
beyond that and and so I made a point
last night to shower at a more
appropriate time and today as you can
tell my hair is totally fine big thank
you to Chelsea Smith for gifting a
subscription at joinpakman.com I so
appreciate that uh super chats more
Super chats are coming in have you heard
or address the repugnant Abomination
Marjorie Taylor green saying adopted
parents are aren't parents I think you
mean adoptive parents yeah she's
disgusting she's really disgusting
David sir about your take on audiobooks
the other day they're great for people
with ADHD easier to pay attention while
doing chores well it's hard to read a
paper book while doing chores anyway
um so I that I can that I can certainly
understand big thank you to Sheila Owen
Sheila gifting a membership at
joinpakman.com to a lucky recipient if
you would like one of the free
memberships go to davidpackman.com slash
free membership how are we doing as far
as YouTube goes it looks like you ended
up with more subscriptions after the
Twitter Fiasco yeah you know what's
really funny hold on I have it here so
we just breached 1.7
million YouTube subscriptions
um the entire Twitter Fiasco
where I quote blamed children for being
killed which was the craziest
interpretation possible
um it it gave us like 35 000 new YouTube
subscribers it's actually crazy if it
weren't for the threats to my family
um it would have been a uniquely
positive thing and everybody else you
know forgot about it none of the none of
those people were none of the people who
were Furious about my tweet actually
watched my show so it turned out that it
was just like a huge audience Boon and
yes we have we have now breached 1.7
million which is I consider it
absolutely fantastic all right let's see
what's going on here Newsmax is covering
this thing let's see Kratts who have run
this government in this country into the
ground to deliver innocent illegal alien
children into the hands of criminals
would you comment please
and and to think Joe Biden has lost
track of more than anything wow this is
so dumb and then over here on right side
broadcasting handles for choose social I
am let's go ahead and blow up your
social media handles right now that's
Liz it's as easy as can possibly be and
Twitter I would love to reach a hundred
thousand on Twitter I know that sounds
crazy but we're not that far away so you
know if you're back on Twitter I know a
lot of you left for a long time I don't
blame you but elon's on there doing some
great things restoring a lot of accounts
so okay I guess now Twitter is good
again because uh she's back on it or
Trump's back on it or something like
that it's pretty crazy Mark says I'm
attracted to dark thick hair and I
literally mainly date Jewish guys your
hair is better than good it is hot well
thank you Mark uh wow I'm flattered
and let's see what we have here oh this
is the one from before okay
right Donald Trump seven minutes late
expected any moment in New Hampshire
it's going to be very important stuff do
we have any voicemails from Whitney
let's see
uh do we have any Whitney voicemails let
me see what I've got for you uh
see if I can find anything
hmm
I actually don't know if I do
see
it's tough to spot the ones from Whitney
and it's hard to explain why
let me see here Whitney Whitney Whitney
Whitney often has a lot to say
uh
no I actually don't see anything from
Whitney interestingly enough
going all the way back to April 6th yeah
no nothing from Whitney but I mean we
can listen to something else how about
oh I don't know uh
trying to find something that will
titillate
hey David you know being that the right
is so incredibly reactionary do you
think that if the left is completely
stopped talking about Trans in all
respects that the right would kind of
just get bored with it and drop it and
that might be an effective strategy it's
an interesting question I I actually
don't know the answer to that I
genuinely don't know the answer to that
would the with the right if the left
stopped reacting every time the right
goes anti-trans now I think the right
would just get away with a lot of
anti-trans insanity quite frankly
Jody says via Super Chat Keith Olbermann
calls Marjorie Taylor green Barney
Rubble it's only slightly less funny
than Pilla
I know I know that is it that actually
has a nice ring to it very very nice
ring to it
um Nick says David sir can you grace us
with Trump audio glitches yeah let me
see what I've got here further
[Music]
and incredible oh these people don't
know what the hell they're doing
divide
one
let me recover my ears for one second
a thanks to miss frazzled for the twitch
Prime subscription putting us at 40.
Tony Tony Crump says is horsey face
Marjorie going to be there stealing the
attention that's below the belt that's a
hit below the ovaries I would say I
don't know that we need to go into that
sort of thing necessarily uh at least I
don't think I need to let me put it that
way where is Trump we never know he's
late all the time it's always very
difficult to know when and where Donald
Trump is
um let's see if I've got another
voicemail
for anybody uh here's one
David love the show
um question for you how come people like
Hannity and people like that they always
refer to Trump they always call him
president Trump president Trump they
never call him what he actually is which
is a private citizen Mr Trump now I know
Hannity never calls so there's two sides
to this obviously when you look at like
for example right side Broadcasting and
they have their headline and it says
awaiting president Trump
there is a convention where once you've
been president you have that title it's
sort of like Hillary is still Hillary
Clinton is still addressed as Madam
Secretary even though she's the former
Secretary of State the difference is
usually on TV when there's going to be
an appearance by a former president it
will say like fmr former abbreviated
former president Trump and places like
right side broadcasting and Newsmax and
to some degree even Fox News they don't
do it so there are two sides to that
there is like you have the title for
life there's that aspect to it
um but there is also the
um other side of it which is it all
relates to their claim that Biden's not
a legitimate president than the entire
thing so it's it it's all pretty gross
stuff to be perfectly Frank all right
let's see if we have any other video
from outside this event here is Marjorie
Taylor Green's boyfriend
um talking to a guy who went from
Connecticut to the rally so what's your
plans you're the you're the youngest one
right now in Connecticut uh where do you
see yourself in 10 years from now he's
the youngest what in Connecticut what
does that even mean well I got inspired
by a man you know quite well his name's
Donald Trump
um and my goal someday is to get higher
up in politics I don't really know where
that's going to lead me but I keep the
same principles that he have never give
up never give in Never back down and as
a young conservative I've taken a lot of
heat especially in school I've been
called all the labels racist sexist I've
been yelled at by teachers because I
stood for the Pledge of Allegiance when
no one else would so I've kind of
learned that especially in Connecticut
which is a quite liberal State you got
to stand for what you believe in so I'd
like to maybe move up and run for office
when I'm done pursuing my education you
know get that degree under your belt and
hopefully maybe one day run for a
national office that's what you got to
do I love it well let's just give a good
shot on his outfit here I love the uh
red pants I just got the new PIN right
yeah yeah and you got this good tie here
you gotta love the tribe Trump dress
right when you're gonna see Mr America
right you have to draw dress
I am not going to comment
I'm I'm not gonna comment that's just
where we are all right it looks like uh
is this Trump is Trump is that is that
Trump
is it no it's not
something something seems to be
happening you campaign from your from
your basement that's pretty much what
you all right any moment now we're gonna
hear from uh Trump
uh graphic Brew says via Super Chat we
won't see Trump until the empty
background chairs are filled he's too
vain to walk by empty seats well seems
to be happening
thanks to
archaean Canadian for the twitch Prime
subscription your number 41. huge thank
you to Russell mckeithan Russell
mckeithan just signed up at
joinpakman.com using the coupon code
indicated coupon code indicated
you can sign up at joinpakman.com and I
will shout you out I really do
appreciate everybody who's been signing
up and supporting it's an absolutely
beautiful thing looks like we are
moments away from Donald Trump's speech
this is supposedly a campaign speech
something makes me think rather than a
campaign speech with policy it's going
to be Trump presenting his usual
grievances that we've become accustomed
to correct me if I'm wrong but I think
that's what is the most likely thing
here all right let's see if we have any
other footage from the uh Trump event
let's see what we have
we might have gotten to the end of it
yeah now it looks like we're elsewhere
oh wait no we got one more guy at Trump
rally with an autographed Marjorie
Taylor green hat nice shot of this hat I
thought it was President Trump's
signature may I just for a second the
great MTG signed his hat there you gotta
love that
Taylor green I hope she's vice president
one day I I really do I love her that
makes two of us there you go that's uh
there he is in love with Marjorie Taylor
green for people who are wondering this
guy really is dating Marjorie Taylor
green
it's not uh it's not it's not a joke
um I mean it's a joke in a sense but
what I mean is it's it's not a it's a
it's a true statement it's a true
statement is what I'm saying
uh okay
big thank you to Nuke dumping in a bomb
of a 50 Super Chat really appreciate
that nuke thank you thank you thank you
very much also thanks to Firefly for the
twitch Prime subscription you're number
43 today we are moments away from Donald
Trump speaking in New Hampshire Trump
expecting to talk about a structuralist
foreign policy perspective today and to
uh again weigh in on the importance of
soft diplomatic power in the Cold War
era it will be a very different speech
than what we're used to from from Trump
he's really going to uh you know
it's going to be a substantive speech as
you can imagine actually it's probably
not if I think about it totally honestly
they seem to be bringing more chairs
onto the stage
um
it's all weird it's all very weird we're
anti-trump day a lot of them lost their
positions so Liz Cheney but but this
team then this looks like an excited
team they're here they're fist bumping
smiling ear to ear I'd say 95 percent of
them are wearing the red Mega hats and I
think it is that a 40 45 or 47 on this
side uh my vision I think we both lack
in that department but at this point the
crowd is even more excited they are
standing
yelling as you can hear it yeah it's
just it's an electric atmosphere there
big thank you to Haley Brady who just
gifted a subscription at joinpakman.com
I really appreciate that Haley a couple
other voicemails maybe we will get to
here if we have time let's see
a bunch of people leaving many many many
many many many voicemails
hey kid I see you tried posting your
on YouTube again I tried what it
what do you mean I tried we've been on
YouTube for over a decade we have 1.7
million subscribers 35 million views a
month what do you mean I tried
that curly-haired little freak that was
on there
you know it still had your name as the
post
well an hour later I went back through
all of YouTube
and guess what you're not on there
what could possibly be happening that
this guy thinks all of my content is
gone from YouTube like whatever you
think of my content
it's pretty damn easy to find my content
on YouTube in fact I think if you just
start typing in well this might depend
but
if you type in d a v i
just with d-a-v-i my name is suggested
in YouTube search
right below David Guetta if you can
imagine and if you search my name it
says
like thirty thousand results how could
this guy possibly have missed that why
don't you try it again all right I'll
try it again I'm gonna try posting
something to YouTube again
money can buy anything I could buy and
sell your whole entire family
and not even miss the money in one day
yeah there's an idea
um
oh God he could buy the entire huh all
right well Trump's here so by the way
that guy's from Mississippi
is it fair to say the Maga people are
like Juggalos they're always saying
they're canceled and hold Gatherings not
the brightest people either
uh
God I don't know what to tell you about
the Maga people I really don't know what
to tell you about them it's it's they're
really in another world
thank you to office drummer the great
office drummer re-upping uh the twitch
Prime subscription check out office
drummer on Twitch and YouTube great
drumming content and office drummer
Omega guy fine but still welcome here we
we everybody's welcome here even though
office drummer is Maga that's okay no
I'm kidding he's as far listen honestly
I don't know
I've never heard uh office drummers
political views but I don't think it's
Maga all right
um welcome everybody Donald Trump
holding a campaign event in New
Hampshire I expect it will be measured
and sober with detailed policy proposals
including a health care proposal a trade
proposal
who am I kidding he'll probably say they
stole the election and trans people are
bad
[Applause]
[Music]
Trump's eyes almost completely swollen
shut at this event you can usually gauge
how high or low energy the speech will
be the more swollen shut the eye the
lower the energy in general
but you never know for sure you never
know for sure and that's why we're going
to be listening very closely here
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks to Graham Henry for the Utah for
the website subscription at
joinpakman.com let's listen let's take
it all in it is campaign 2024 in full
swing
well thank you very much what our group
this is
and we want to thank the Fire Marshals
because they had they had a lot of work
to do to get this crowd we had a lot of
people outside thousands and reports are
there's like a couple thousand people
there total honored to be here in
Manchester a place that I've gotten to
know very well or the political Trail
and love and in particular to be in the
great state of New Hampshire let's
actually go to a different feed
as I promised you and as you know from
the beginning I fought to protect and
defend New Hampshire's beloved first in
the nation primary and you got it
you got it
and next year we're going to make
history together when we win New
Hampshire primary for the third straight
time
we've had a lot of success here today
I'm deeply honored to receive the
endorsements of more than 50 New
Hampshire state legislators many of whom
are on stage with us and some of whom
are in the audience because I think
structurally maybe the stage couldn't
take it
but I just want to introduce them if I
could quickly they're great people they
went out there right right from the
beginning sometimes Trump will name 50
people at the top of a speech and
mispronounce many of the names I mean
they're just special people
Representatives Kimberly I bear
Louis Andrus
Glenn belly
Harry Bean
Jacob Brew yard
Claudia
Tim Cahill
s
Brian Cole Juve
[Applause]
oh man
Ron Dunn
Tracy Emrick thank you Tracy
Keith air
Larry gagne
a rhino named Mitt Romney red Gorski
Gerald Griffin we've endorsed JP right
JD Mandel
Juliet Harvey bolia
oh God Greg Gregory Hill thank you
Gregory
Thomas kuczynski
sepha Hyde Kelly
Stephen Kennedy
Abul Khan this is really the way to fire
up a crowd read a list of 50 names in
the first two minutes of your speech
Just
public speaking 101 this is the way they
teach it at MIT McDonald
Charles Melvin
Dane Nagel thank you Dan
Christine Perez
[Applause]
Joseph petray
Tom plausage
John puterstick
are these all real names Kevin Pratt
Arlene cortielo
Andrew renzolo
Jennifer Rhodes
Carrie Roy
John Sellers thank you John
Vanessa Sheehan
Lisa smart look let's see these are
endorsements how good is this
Lisa smart
thank you these are endorsements
James spiling
isn't it Spillane
James Summers
Jeffrey tenjar
president Donald J Trump
dick Thaxton
Jordan yearly
Jordan thank you
Lily Walsh
[Music]
Kenneth Weiler
Robert weary
and Clayton wood
wow we finally got to the end
and somebody said you think I should
introduce him it's 51 should I I said
you know what they were out there at the
front many of them were here from the
beginning beginning I said I'll take the
time you know I'm not sure if television
is too thrilled look at all these people
I don't know if television's thrilled
but we're thrilled right we're thrilled
this is crazy what an electric
atmosphere inside the venue Bruce Breton
and Lou gargiolo who have been with us
for
a long time right from the beginning
thank you both right this is worse than
when I thank members I have to tell you
and I want to thank president of the New
Hampshire Federation of college
Republicans Harrison spalthorph
comparison wherever you may be thank you
Harrison
New Hampshire Federation of Republican
women president Elizabeth Gerard thank
you Elizabeth
thank you
the founder of the 603 Alliance friend
Wendell bow
and also my New Hampshire senior advisor
who's been with me for a long time asked
Steve stepanek thank you very much
great job great job from day one my
state director Trevor knew clearly
thank you very much as well as somebody
who really did a great job ran for
office did very well Caroline Levitt
thank you thank you
did a great job
you could actually chart on a graph with
X and Y axes number of names read by
Trump possibility that he mangles one
and I think it would basically
you know it would rapidly approach 99.9
percent maybe 15 maybe before that but
he's been a friend of mine for a long
time loves this state and he's a
political Pro Corey Lewandowski where is
he oh God tourism
he's such such a good guy thank you
Corey
and by the way we will take a few
questions if you want after we're
finished is that okay
so you can think otherwise if I do it
right at the end that's a better way to
do it I'll finish and there's any
questions okay let's get out of here now
you have a whole little time to think
about it but we'll take a few questions
okay
you think Biden takes questions I don't
think so
[Applause]
he said call this one this is what she's
going to ask and here's the answer they
never did that with me in the White
House I can tell you on Tuesday Joe
Biden officially announced that he will
seek four more disastrous years
[Applause]
as you know I've done very well against
crooked Hillary Clinton
but
today I'm going to do sudden
the most important part of what I'm
going to say because this is going to be
a major announcement are you ready is
everybody ready
I will be retiring the name crooked from
Hillary Clinton and her moniker
and I'm gonna give her a new name I
don't know like maybe lovely Hillary or
beautiful Hillary but I'm going to
retire
the name crooked so that we can use the
name for Joe Biden because he'll be
known from now on as crooked Joe Biden
all right
Trump just gained a million votes folks
you would think that Hillary would be
very happy today she'll be and
she's out there someplace celebrating I
don't think she cares because there's
never been anyone in the history of
American politics so crooked or
dishonest as Joe Biden
and the Press absolutely refuses to
report it all that press back there
because frankly they're just as crooked
as he is as they are they're just as
crooked the choice of this election is
now between strength and weakness
between success or failure between
safety or Anarchy between peace or
conflict and prosperity or catastrophe
we are living in a catastrophe with your
vote on November 5th 2024 we're going to
crush Joe Biden and the
the White House that gorgeous beautiful
white house we have to take it back
we're going to beat him at The Ballot
Box so we're going to see guys recycling
an old nickname is not exactly high
energy
Biden announced
his presidential campaign by get this a
pre-packaged video I was going to do
that for you today I'll do a little
video send it up to New Hampshire you
wouldn't have been very happy about that
but when you're running for president do
you think at least one time you get up
and say I'm running for president uh
where where am I going where the hell am
I going I want to get out oh no over
there over there
you can tell from the speech so far that
Trump would do a lot for the middle
class if you were elected can't you
a pre-packaged video
that took supposedly seven takes to get
it right
if right is what you want to call it
it he says he's running because Trump
and mega pose a threat to democracy can
you believe it
true
I'm going to explain Maga is make
America great again right
no no threat there
no it's uh Biden who poses the threat to
democracy because he is grossly
incompetent has no idea what he's doing
and basically he doesn't have a clue and
that's a very bad position to put our
country in our country is in very very
dangerous in a very dangerous position
right now very very dangerous we're now
in a nation and we are a nation in
serious decline a nation that has lost
its way
we're led by a hopeless person but we
will win in 2024 and make America great
again we can do it it's not too late
it's not too late
but we've got a year and a half to go
that's a long time with what's happening
to our country that's a long time still
with such a calamitous presidency it's
almost inconceivable that Biden would
have even thought of running for
re-election he's destroyed our country
and yet he says in his recorded piece
that he wants to finish the job that's
right he wants to finish the job of
destroying our country
but on that he's actually very close he
is very close to finishing the job
unfortunately
one of the most important issues in this
campaign will be which candidate can
risk and this this country needs to win
very rescue America from the wreckage of
the Biden economy under my leadership we
built the greatest economy in the
history of the world in fact we actually
did it twice because horrible gifts from
China came over covet or the China virus
as many people say actually in New
Hampshire is a China virus pretty much
but now we will do it again we will do
it again we pass the largest tax cuts
and reforms in American history we cut
more job-killing regulations than any
Administration ever also in history we
achieved American Energy Independence
and we were about set to do
American Energy dominance bigger than
Saudi Arabia bigger than Russia combined
times two and we slash the price of
gasoline down all the way down to a
dollar 87 a gallon doesn't that sound
good
now of course it was way up from that
when Trump left office who cares right
putting your energy now everything's up
now it's happening to everything
thank you
thanks to our policies the typical New
Hampshire family saw their annual income
Rise by six thousand dollars the largest
increase in recorded history the largest
nobody's ever seen that by six thousand
dollars everybody was happy for decades
the corrupt globalist establishment
savagely betrayed New Hampshire workers
you know that better than most I see
those I see those beautiful Factory
buildings some are now apartment houses
and some are now senior citizens but the
factor is this what you had to do with
the factories there's so many gone your
State lost one in four manufacturing
jobs after the NAFTA disaster in China's
entrance into the World Trade
Organization but after years so it's
basically the same speech he gave in
2016 and 2020 with no proposed Solutions
or the same vague Solutions he already
failed to provide raising real questions
as to if he already didn't do it when he
had four years how is he going to do it
next time
that's considered now the best trade
deal ever made so good in fact that
Mexico and Canada are now trying to
renegotiate the deal with the Biden
Administration
don't talk about it don't do it somebody
over there told me it's unfair I said
you know what we lived with unfair for
decades now they say it's unfair no we
made a great deal and you're all
manufacturers Farmers everybody is
benefiting usmca we're very proud of
that don't let them renegotiate I
withdrew from the job crushing
trans-pacific partnership that would
have totally destroyed this country
they're all set to sign Obama
Barack Hussein Obama they were all set
to sign it and I stood up to China like
no Administration has ever done before
not quite
bringing in hundreds and hundreds of
billions of dollars pouring into our
treasury from China when no other
president had gotten even 10 cents not
one president got China and I literally
mean not 10 cents we got hundreds of
billions of dollars
I don't think they like me too much but
that's okay
well everybody else is paid off by China
including by the way our president okay
it's a big problem
you wonder why he does nothing about
China why he doesn't do what he's
supposed to be doing because he got
millions of dollars from China you see
it I made big Promises to the people of
New Hampshire and as your president I
kept every single promise
right
replacement for ObamaCare wall across
the entire border that Mexico will pay
for fixing trade solving the
israeli-palestinian conflict yeah come
on guys the money we were taking in from
China we took a little bit out like a
little bit hundreds of millions of
dollars by the way but that's a lot to a
lobsterman and we uh we brought it back
I made a deal with the European Union to
completely eliminate tariffs on American
lobster you know that they were charging
us big tariffs so that we couldn't sell
to them the first EU tariff reduction on
any product in over 20 years nobody ever
asked the EU or if they did they didn't
get it because they're very difficult
people to deal with I want to tell you
that They Don't Care About Us they care
about them and maybe that's the way it's
supposed to be right
I also opened up 5 000 square miles of
ocean that Barack Obama closed to New
England fishermen you know about that
whoa
but you also know I opened them up
totally nobody could even tell me why
they closed they get miles and miles of
beautiful ocean front and now I
understand that they want to close it up
again is that true I can't
I can't believe it I can't believe it
yeah let Canada let Canada do all you
know Canada is the one that wanted it
closed because they want to do the
business and I gave our Farmers 28
billion dollars out of the tariffs that
we took in from China because they were
treated very unfairly I said
how much would it be they said
approximately 28 billion I said I'm
going to take it from China China paid
them 28 billion dollars who else is
going to do that one okay
tell that one to president she
mind giving our Farmers 28 billion
actually better than that we signed an
incredible trade what's interesting is
that the speech isn't about anything
like there's no there's no takeaway like
if you leave you go you know I'm really
interested in how Trump laid out his
vision as to how health care should be
decoupled from employment and like
there's just it's just rambling it's not
about anything I put America first
everything
when I left office we handed Joe Biden
the fastest economic recovery ever
recorded all with no inflation here's an
idea what if I go to New Hampshire and
for 90 minutes do Biden dementia
material and rehash my phrases from uh
2016. take a couple questions and glitch
badly what do you think let's do it
let's fly you there right away sir you
raised everything and now everything's
so high and now they've taken on their
own inflationary Trend It's Not Just
Energy anymore
but they did that with energy they
destroyed our economy with the high
prices all electric cars oh that's
wonderful everybody they don't they
don't have enough electric to turn on
the lights
and now they're going to say let's let's
do all electric I love electric cars
they go for about an hour and a half
then you're in the middle of nowhere
you're saying how do I get you know I
recently drove from uh from Brooklyn to
Montreal Canada in the electric car
stopped for a 15-minute charge during a
diaper change not my diaper obviously my
baby daughter and it went beautifully
beautifully filled with chargers in
Canada 0.1 percent and the forecast show
it's going to be getting much much worse
so we're at one percent
and getting worse that doesn't sound too
prosperous does it look at these other
countries that are eating our lunch I
had them they were doing anything they
could they respected Your Leader they
respected your country I want to tell
you they saw me coming they weren't
happy
they weren't happy
every time France or one of the
countries but France and particularly
they were a little difficult I I really
like their leader but he's a very
difficult guy and whenever he got cute
and wanted to tax our people or our
companies I just said that's okay we're
going to put a 100 percent tariff on all
wine and champagne coming into the
United States they would say no no no we
will not do it we have decided we won't
do it
no but I don't think they do that I
don't think they do that in this group
Here China we should have tremendous
power we have tremendous economic power
that we don't use but you know uh we
better be smart because soon we're not
going to have economic France especially
is just desperate for our wine you know
that golf is the typical family has lost
over seven thousand four hundred dollars
in annual income think of that inflation
is out of control banks are collapsing
look at the bottom of the screen new
scans discover links to Jesus did you
see that at the bottom pictures are down
24 months in a row overwhelming evidence
of the supernatural
Special Report oh my God the trade
deficit has surged to a record one
trillion dollars household wealth is
declined by four trillion dollars these
are numbers that nobody's ever seen
before you know they stand up in the
center door or the economy is good the
economy is horrible after Biden shut
down the Keystone XL pipeline that I
started
and pass the 20 billion dollar tax cycle
in American Energy gas prices in New
Hampshire hey look at this Trump booming
economy turned to shreds under Biden
what about providing a single fact to
back that up unemployment I mean give us
give us a fact give us something there's
the highest electricity costs in the
entire nation tell your Governor he
ought to work on that a little bit
you know that's it
you have the highest cost of the entire
nation
I will quickly be able to cut that
number in half or more than that
algorithm
nobody knew that
New Hampshire has the highest
electricity because I think the highest
energy cost but highest electricity
costs in the nation doesn't he say that
in every state he goes to now like you
guys are suffering the worst in the
country highest electric costs in the
nation they didn't want to give you
they don't want you driving like how
about driving for about an hour and 15
minutes and then say it's time to get
them time to get a charge
Joe Biden cares only about enriching his
own family I care about enriching your
family and you
a Biden Victory will be
China and truly great for these
globalists we've got a lot of globalists
trump Victory will be bad for the
globalists the Rhinos the Communists the
Marxist but it will be great for the
hard-working people of New Hampshire
what a crowd within hours of my
inauguration I will begin the process of
terminating every Biden policy that is
brutalizing New Hampshire
and all U.S workers
what I would love to hear Trump explain
is if you start with the results of 2020
where has Trump gained support it's like
certainly not in not in Arizona not in
Wisconsin where does Trump gained
support since 2020 that would then get
him to a victory when I did that
a team cut down it was amazing actually
but they put many of them back but they
haven't been able to up your taxes yet
because we have a very strong Bill we've
got we went through everything to make
sure that nobody could tamper with it
but they're trying they're trying to
raise your taxes very greatly instead of
growing the size and scope of the
federal government every year we will
shrink it every year with aggressive
cost reduction targets for each Federal
Department
but we'll take care of our military we
have to we have no choice
a lot of Bad actors out there looking to
do harm we will take care of our
military you know I rebuilt our entire
military they gave 85 billion of it to
Afghanistan but
probably the most embarrassing moment in
the history of our country 85 billion
dollars worth of brand new military
equipment I know if I think of the top
10 embarrassing moments they all involve
Trump made New Hampshire a manufacturing
and Industrial Powerhouse in the old
days remember the old days you see those
buildings all over and you say wow
I did a great job in renegotiating trade
deals with other countries they were the
worst the most horrible deals I've ever
seen I'd often wonder to myself who the
hell negotiated these deals they were so
bad
you'd lay you say it they were either
like very very stupid people or they
hated our country could only be one of
two I think both yeah they probably
I think I think maybe both now the worst
deals I've ever seen with Japan and with
South Korea Mexico Canada China all of
these countries it was uh just uh
amazing that how bad they were and you
know like South Korea we take care of
their economy we take care of everything
we take care of the military they're
right next door to Kim Jong-un he and I
have a very good relationship people
would say it's not good to have a good
relay yeah it's very good to have a good
relationship it really is
but he's not so happy with uh Biden
he says bad things about Biden but what
I really wanted to do the Trump
reciprocal tradec you know what that is
that we'll go along with the Trump tax
cuts which they haven't been able to
terminate because we've drawn them so
powerfully under the reciprocal trade
Act
this is think of this every country do
we have any children here no
couple
close close at such a good looking good
put your hands over your ears
every country you'll hear it soon enough
every country is screwing us right so
they've all charged us taxes and trade
barriers India China everyone Europe by
the way all over Europe
under the Trump reciprocal trade act if
India as an example of China Europe any
any place any country charges us let's
say 100 or 200 percent that's what they
do you could ask Carly Davidson you
could ask a lot of companies that are
unable to put their product into these
countries because what they do what they
do they make it impossible we
immediately charge them the exact same
thing it's called reciprocal reciprocal
reciprocal
some just learned that word today sounds
good so if India charges our companies a
hundred we charge their companies a
hundreds very simple and yet we have
people in Congress that say no I don't
think that's good anybody that says
that's no good very interesting Lindsey
Graham the progressive from South
Carolina
no he's a progressor
but he's got some good things too okay
but Lindsey Graham I said to him Lindsay
you got to go along with this we were
all set to get it done you got to go
along with this he says so let me let me
get this straight if they charge us we
charge them the same thing he said it's
not his strength other things are his
strength he said so they charge us we
charge them the same thing right yeah
you got my vote
that's so easy but you know you have
guys in there that I guess campaign
contributions are much worse than that
maybe maybe campaign contributions that
aren't recorded
but can you imagine but we were close to
getting that done and then the election
was rigged but we would have had that
done there it is and and done very very
quickly one of two things will happen
they will get rid of the tariffs on us
they'll most likely get rid of them if
you start doing this because we have
countries that it's so imbalanced so
unfair the deficits are massive as an
example with China 600 billion dollars
we lose every year I got it down way
down and then we had a little little
surprise on an election and they're way
up now they're doing better than they've
ever done but they'll leave them the
United States will make a fortune on
this the United States will make an
absolute Fortune get rid of your
deficits and other countries won't go
around saying we're stupid people
because that's what they say right now
we're stupid people to allow this to
happen where they charge us or we don't
charge them cars as an example in China
you make a car in America sends it to
China you have to pay a fortune to get
it in you have to like nine different
tax structures they can make cars and
send them into us we did put some taxes
on though I will tell you that I was
ready to
get all of this past
and we had great support when we got hit
with the election and we got hit with
the covet and we got it with everything
you could get hit with and then we
rebuilt it and we had the stock market
actually higher than it was just prior
to covet when you think of it pretty
amazing as far as the great speeches of
American History go
I don't know that this one's going to
make the list they give Biden credit he
doesn't know he's alive I mean jeez
under the Trump reciprocal trade act
companies factories and jobs will come
roaring back into our country and
massive deficits that we've been paying
for decades and decades going to
disappear the deficits will disappear
almost overnight I will also revoke
China's most favored nation trade status
you believe it
they were given a most favorite Nation
because they say they're a growing
Nation well we're a growing Nation also
okay if they're a growing Nation then
we're a growing Nation I will gain total
independence from China economically
I'll hold the Chinese Communist Party
accountable for unleashing the China
virus upon the world
and nobody can pay
the cost of what that cost the lives
number one the lives all of the millions
and millions of lives but you're talking
about 50 to 60 trillion dollars China
doesn't have it nobody has that but
something will happen there's going to
be something happening just like I got
28 billion dollars for the farmers
something's going to happen because what
what took place there is disgraceful and
it did come from the Wuhan Labs as I
said from day one Biden is proposing a
4.7 trillion dollar tax High
congratulations I on the other hand will
deliver tax cuts energy price cuts and
interest rates cuts the likes of which
you have never seen before how will he
deliver interest rate Cuts how exactly
how
and the economy is doing terribly unlike
Rhonda Sanctus the bushes the Ryan's the
robes call row he's another Beauty the
rhinos and the Democrats I will always
protect Social Security and Medicare for
our great seniors
I will end Joe Biden's war on American
Energy and immediately begin the process
of expediting
construction of new natural gas
pipelines to New England again you pay
the highest prices in the country you
know uh he's not going to do that he is
not going to start constructing new
natural gas pipelines to New England
through New York state where they could
really use the jobs really really use
the jobs
into New England you know where you get
a lot of your energy from is Russia they
have Russian ships out there for years
they've had Russian ships and if they
did a pipeline going through
a place in New York state that needs it
so badly they need the jobs this would
be a positive and you don't see it it's
underground and the environmentalists
and the governors and once you get that
done you're you're I'll tell you you're
and I will do it we'll do whatever you
have to do okay
we'll do none of it it's a simple
pipeline
New York has fought it off for years
it's not going to happen not going to
happen your prices will drop in half and
much more than that you're paying so
much higher than anybody else it's
that's the reason
but we love New York other than that
right okay other than that but now they
have to they have to do that they have
to do that we're all part of a team and
if you want to buy a car powered by an
internal combustion engine or a hybrid
or if you want to buy an electric car
some people like an electric car like
what four percent of the people
he'll be able to do it what on Earth is
there not to like about electric cars
it's a really really weird uh scapegoat
I can't see ever going back to a gas
powered vehicle
why why why would I imagine them saying
you can only buy electric cars when they
don't go
far enough they don't drive long enough
when some people don't like them and
when the batteries are all made 100 in
China or in areas that China controls
who is coming up when we have more
Liquid Gold under our feet than any
other country including Saudi Arabia and
Russia
but we're not allowed to use them
the electric car takes so much energy to
create the battery that they won't break
even environmentally if you're a
believer in that the making of the
battery throws off more
let's call it dirt into the air dirt
into the air now of course there is a
question as to the carbon footprint of
the battery creation but that is going
to only improve over time the longer you
drive the car the more that that's
mitigated and of course it will continue
improving and improving and improving as
the efficiency improves up position
research this is really a lot of dirt
when you look at it you know I saw this
saying about a month ago I realized how
crazy the borders ridiculous we don't
want open borders April fools right
remember he says it's like everything's
April Fool's like all electric cars
April Fool say I don't mind electric
cars you should have everything some
people might like electric some people
might like something else some people
might like a motor scooter let them get
whatever the hell they want but to to
force them when we don't have enough
electricity for ourselves you go out to
California they want all electric cars
and yet they have brownouts during the
summer for a black house a whole state
goes out and then they say oh let's hook
up another couple of million anybody
know the difference between a brownout
and a blackout it's crazy and that's why
I say April fools everything they don't
want voter ID how simple is voter ID we
don't want voter ID why don't they want
voter ID because they want to cheat
that's all
our opponents know that no one can match
us on the economy and that's the reason
that we're way up in the polls we have
polls I'm going to show you a couple of
them oh no so today very respected poll
came out Emerson big big poll it has
Trump
huge flagpole
[Music]
thank you
people were starting to come thank you
very much and I love you too that's why
I'm doing this I had a nice life
I had a nice life I didn't have to go
before grand juries every time I fly
over a state if I fly over a state that
happens to be Democrat run
they send me a subpoena to go before a
Grandeur these people are sick they're
weaponizing that stuff but you know
these polls are amazing so today's very
very uh important and big Emerson poll
came out so it has trumpets 62 percent
to Sanctus at 16. Mike Benson seven
obviously people are dreaming of energy
Independence a strong military like you
had and borders and low taxes that are
strong we want strong borders we want
low taxes we want low interest rates we
want to be respected throughout the
world not left I will laugh that
you know I I said it as speech recently
they said somebody said what do you
think about she I said he's a very
powerful strong man he's at the top of
his game the fake news media said how
dare they say that I said what am I
going to say he controls 1.5 billion
people no he's not at the top of his
game uh the same thing with other
leaders they're sharp they're smart
they're at the top of the game we're the
only one that has one that's not and
he's not close and he never really had a
top of the game if you go back 25 years
in this week's big morning console poll
that's another big one Trump is leading
by 37 points at last week this really is
like 2016 when Trump would go out at
rallies and just read polls he's
recreating 2016 all over again Steve
just keep working because
under the clarity
Clarity Sanctus being at 20 pence at
four Nikki Haley at four and sloppy
Chris Christie at less than one percent
which by the way is subsidiously better
than he did seven years ago
right here in New Hampshire remember he
was less than one percent so now he's
still less than one percent
but he's doing much better you know got
a big mouth that's all he's got in
Massachusetts
in Massachusetts your neighbor
70 for Trump
and in the Florida voice poll this is
Florida we're talking about 80 percent
for Trump 80. with the Florida boys
in a great place South Carolina we have
a 22 point lead in the victory poll of
Iowa it's Trump 54 to Sanctus you
understand these are just primary polls
it's like we know Trump's leading the if
a former president can't win his own
primary something's wrong the question
is what are the general election polls
looking like I just saw that
that's pretty good you're doing a good
job sir you're doing a good job
we're at 51 with all these people
running all these people 51 we're up 33
points but we will not play prevent
defense you ever see the NFL they hold a
team scoreless for almost four quarters
they just have to do it one more time
one more series and they say we're going
to go prevent touchdown touchdown we
don't play prevent defense it prevents
you from winning right prevent defense
prevents you from winning that's the
worst defense should really do uh Sports
commentary team illegal prevents say bet
on the opponent and then they want to
do something under debates think of this
they want to debate they want to have I
have people at one half of one percent
one quarter of one percent one percent
three percent two percent four percent
seven percent and the Sanctus is very
low and crashing he's crashing and
burning don't forget when he came to me
he was at three percent
so he failed in this campaign then I
endorsed him
which I could have done without but I
endorsed them and he went up a lot but
he went up and he won but Trump doesn't
mention in the story is that DeSantis
went up months after the endorsement
getting a chance to campaign without
Trump to put it mildly to put it mildly
but so these debates you know uh
Nixon and Reagan and
uh bush bush number one uh others
no they didn't debate in the primaries
they didn't debate I mean seriously you
look at the boards and you see these
things one percent one percent two
percent one percent three percent and
you look at it isn't he talking about
when those other folks were incumbents
Trump's not an incumbent anymore it's an
Open Primary it's a totally different
situation you're running your country
but I do look forward to the debate with
uh Joe no
corrupt
with crooked
crooked Joe
no I look forward to that remember last
time I said where and why did you accept
three and a half million dollars
remember that why did you accept on the
debate stage I had that guy Chris
Wallace how's he doing how's his career
going I don't know not too good he
always wanted to be his father Mike but
it's all grievances all the way down
it's called lack of talent but think of
this think of this remember in the
debate stage I said to Biden I said why
did you accept three and a half million
dollars from the mayor of moscow's wife
and Chris Wallace he was he didn't know
how to answer the question Chris Wallace
said you shouldn't be asking that
question that has a I said has a lot to
do why did he get three and a half
million dollars from Moscow he didn't do
anything for it and Chris Wallace
stopped him from giving an answer which
he didn't have by the way saved him they
want me to go to the Reagan Library as
an example which is nobody knew this
until I brought it up yesterday which is
run by a guy named Fred Ryan he is the
chairman and CEO of the Washington Post
can you believe this could only happen
The Washington Post the enemy of the
people The Washington Post think of this
is running the Reagan Library I think
Ronald Reagan would be spinning in his
grave okay
but you say how did that happen but they
want me to go and sadly your Governor
sununu doesn't register
really a Gish gallop
now instead of a nest isn't there a
nasty guy all over the map
you know it's funny his father was very
very tough
but when I won he became one of my best
supporters he really was he really was
great but he was really tough this guy
doesn't have the same qualities but you
know what you think of it he could have
run he could have had a senate seat
would have helped so much you know he's
playing games but sununu if you take a
look at what he's done it's crazy he's
we're leading him I guess 58 to seven in
your state
you saw the poll 58-7 what and now if he
ran for the Senate he probably couldn't
win even you know if you if you put him
back in that same position but he could
have really made an impact he could have
run for the Senate would have probably
easily won because of the family name
would have won and that would have been
a tremendous thing instead he wants to
play games with running for president
where he's registered at less than one
percent I don't think he's going to make
it if he made it it would be the biggest
it would be the biggest upset in the
history of politics any country will
include every single country all over
the world
and he should stop being a nasty guy and
telling people that I won't win in the
general election which I will remember
speaking of which we're leading Biden by
seven points in Rasmussen poll
rasmussen's worthless look at actual
polls Harvard Paul Harvard Harris
and by 11 points in another poll and by
the way one I won't name the same people
that said the same thing in 2016 well
maybe he'll win here but he's not going
to win in the General Lake they love
that that's the only narrative they have
left
but we're winning against everybody and
we're doing just as well just as well in
the general election so just to
interject some truth now of course this
can change of course it can change but
look at this a minus rated Emerson
College poll which Trump just touted as
one of the best polls it has Biden
leading Trump and Biden leading DeSantis
by Trump's own statement five minutes
ago that's a good poll because these are
incredible people
I don't even care if you helped me
campaign you don't have to help me what
I want you to do is help me on Election
evening which is no longer election
evening it's election period because
these people have like
a month and two months to look around
and play around with the votes how
people let this happen we got to go to
all paper ballots voter ID
same day voting one day
the people clapping wide widely use
other methods for voting guys
how do you tabulate the results what do
everybody wait the nation Waits it's a
disgrace what's happened and I asked the
people on stage and we have a lot of
people in the audience that are great
politicians and very important for your
state to I don't want help I don't even
want help with the vote I just want help
on making sure the vote is cast and
counted fairly you know Lenin
Lenin did anyone ever hear of Blood In
Blood the vote counter is far more
important than the candidate has anyone
ever heard that's Lenin Lenin as they
say as they say in Russia
but uh no the vote counter is far more
important it's very sad we did so
unbelievably we've got more votes than
any sitting president by far we've got
millions of more votes than Barack
Hussein Obama
he lost the popular vote by 8 million
yeah
about 10 15 in the evening then all of a
sudden we said what's going on here now
we gotta we got to straighten out our
borders got to straighten out our
elections because we're like a we're
like a third world country
these incredible poll numbers are one of
the main reasons that the Marxist left
is coming after us using the criminal
justice system for massive election
interface is there a Marxist left I
still haven't met any of the marxists
here with our elections through the use
of the doj and the FBI attorney generals
and Local District Attorneys who
actually they actually you know the
district attorney we have in New York
he's reporting into Washington they sent
one of the top guys from Washington to
help him run his office
that's very that's beautiful isn't it a
wonderful life but in the end they're
not coming after me they're coming after
you and I'm just standing in their way
I'm just standing I will always stand in
their way
but we can't let that happen
because that's going to a lower level
even than what happened
in 2020 that's going in my opinion to a
lower level that even happened in 2020
and they're working on I got more DA's
and local people people nobody ever
heard of we want the president in to
testify or what I have nothing to do
with it well we want them in any way to
testify maybe he'll make a mistake maybe
he'll do something it's a disgrace
what's happening with our country is a
disgrace and it's a laughing stock all
over the world as the endless witch
hunts and persecutions reveal our
enemies are desperate to stop us because
they know we are the only ones who can
stop them they know that there's never
been a movement like this by the way
thank God the history of our country
there's never been a movement like Mecca
make America great thank God for that
we've never had a meeting
and with all of them look it's a lot of
fake news with all of the news back
there nobody's ever questioned it you
know if I say something and I'm like
slightly off they say oh he made a
mistake he this that you know these
people I've never been challenged I say
it all the time are you hearing me
there's never been a movement in history
in history like Maga make America great
again
but unlike other politicians the harder
our enemies hit me the stronger and more
determined we are and that's as a party
and as a movement itself they hit me and
we're all together I'm with you you're
with me and uh the harder they hit the
better we do you saw that a couple of
weeks ago with these fakes these fakers
in recent months I've been laying out a
bold forward-looking vision for what we
will do when we become the 47th
president of the United States we will
become the 47th president
those sound like some weird pronouns
guys
before I even arrive that's we singular
after I win the presidency I will have
the horrible war between Russia and
Ukraine settled would have never
happened that war with it I spoke to
Putin about it there was no chance that
he would have gone in with me as
president and it was no chance that
President XI of China would have gone
into Taiwan
I was the only president in decades who
didn't start a war you know that
everyone said oh he's going to start a
workers because they said I had that
personality to start a war they remember
that oh we can't vote for him he's going
to settle with no I used my personality
though we didn't have to have wars ah
and I got out of Wars including knocking
the hell out of Isis took over a hundred
percent of the Isis California
[Applause]
I took over 99 of the Isis caliphate I
said all right we're going home let's
get our great soldiers we're bringing
them home and the media started say well
why not a hundred I said you know what
we better finish it off because they'll
say I left early and we knocked the hell
out of them that was the end of that we
took over a hundred percent we came home
but now I understand they're rebuilding
again because they have no respect for
our country standing before you today I
am the only candidate who can make this
promise I will prevent world war three
right
super believable
and very sadly there's never been talk
like what you're hearing now because
this guy doesn't have a clue how to
speak he's too tough when he should be
soft he's too soft when he should be
tough he says things that are so bad
provokes and then shows weakness he it's
the craziest thing he says just the
opposite of what you have to say I know
Putin very well I know she very well I
know Kim Jong-un if I didn't take over
from Obama if he had another year you
would have had a nuclear war with Kim
Jong-un of North Korea you would have
had a nuclear war
then when I got along with them everyone
hated the fake news hated that I got
along he got so long it did a good thing
to get along with a guy with 5 000
nuclear weapons that's okay
but I did get along with I got along
with a lot of people that uh people are
surprised really surprised that's why we
had no Wars and they would have never
gone in and Associate all those people
dead in Ukraine far more than you think
far more than they report these phony
numbers where a city is blown up
buildings all crushed to the ground
there's nothing standing and they say
nobody was killed two people were hurt
hundreds of people thousands of people
were killed these numbers are far
greater and far worse than you hear when
I get back into the Oval Office we will
totally obliterate the Deep state
look at the cheers for it's like dude
what are you talking about established a
Truth and Reconciliation Commission to
declassify and publish all documents on
deep State spying censorship and
Corruption
by the way they spider in my campaign
they did not imagine if we let's take
Barack Hussein Obama let's say we
spotted his campaign you got caught what
do you think would happen you think it
would just be some stories
in only a few newspapers because most of
them don't even want to write it it
would have been they would have brought
back the electric chair that's what they
would have done to disgrace it's a
disgrace unequal Justice
and I will require every federal
employee to pass a new civil service
test how about the president let's start
with the president
demonstrating an understanding of our
constitution
to stop the local Marxist prosecutors
who release rapists and murderers while
persecuting conservatives on day one of
my new Administration I will direct the
doj to investigate every radical
district attorney and attorney general
in America for their illegal racist in
reverse
enforcement of the law no you won't
I will quickly restore the most secure
Border in U.S history just as we had
three years ago we had the strongest
most powerful most secure Border in the
history of our country three years ago
we had the most secure we built hundreds
of miles of wall it worked by the way
then we were we were going to do 200
more miles of wall in certain areas
where we could see it was a little
weaker than we wanted it we started that
could have been finished in three weeks
if he did it we had this stuff ordered
he took it away and hid it so that Texas
and Arizona couldn't use it and that's
what I said I guess they really do want
open borders and they actually want open
borders and nobody understands this
story is a complete lie I've debunked it
in detail on my YouTube channel since
why do they want that why do you want
people from prisons and mental
institutions and insane asylums that's a
step above that Silence of the Lamb type
okay why do we want these people in our
country why are we allowing them and you
know you have to see these other
countries they are I mean they've never
had it so good their prisons are emptied
out into the U.S they have no more costs
they don't want to take care of these
people for 70 years which is what you
could have
I mean they have this MS-13 you saw what
happened yesterday with this killer this
Dougie was an MS-13 the level of
violence they called it demonic demonic
the level of violence is incredible we
have become a Dumping Ground for the
entire world the money they saved no
prisons no mental institutions sometimes
there was a story recently about it and
what big mythology or psychiatrist but a
psychologist who worked in mental Wards
in South America Wards and he said I
worked 24 a good man he worked 24 hours
a day taking care of very mentally ill
people
and he was sitting there reading a
newspaper and they asked him what what's
he doing he said I have no more work the
people have all been let go into the
United States can you this is what we're
doing that's one of the dumbest stories
that he tells this is what we're doing
and this you pay
for it we can get a
little this is what we're paying
repair and the crime that you have
you have wait till you see this but he
said they've let him go in the United
States but this is not true with the
three or four countries that we think of
Honduras and Mexico El Salvador this
isn't
just that little area this is all over
the world they're letting them in from
all over the world they're coming in
they're coming through the southern
border and we had it stopped up one of
the very first bills I signed will be
for a massive increase in Border Patrol
and colossal increase in the number of
ice deportation officers
we're going to follow the Eisenhower
model people don't realize it with
Eisenhower he was very tough for an
illegal immigration a lot of people
don't realize that he was really tough
on illegal immigration we will use all
necessary State local Federal and
Military resources to carry out the
largest domestic deportation operation
in American history
and they'll take them back to
you know that story they weren't taking
them back and I said good if they don't
take it they weren't taking them back
for decades
and the generals came up to sure they
won't take them back sir sir and I said
well uh do we give them any money like
any kind of subsidies or anything yes
sir I'd like to find out until he comes
back 750 million dollars you have 750 so
I said listen to three countries I said
no more money for them starting this
afternoon at five o'clock
the next morning I got three calls from
three presidents of three countries nice
people they're smart I don't hold it
against them
they got away with it for years they put
airplanes on the runways when we're
flying in with prisoners or MS-13 people
that are you don't want in this country
believe me these are vicious vicious the
most violent gang in the world probably
almost definitely and they put airplanes
so you couldn't land the plane so I said
uh how much 750 I say here's what we're
doing immediately you're going to stop
payment of all money going to these
countries you're going to stop payment
now next day you get three calls
the presidents of those countries
separate call studies sir I understand
there's a misunderstanding yeah yeah we
want your MS-13 killers that you sent
over here we want them back and we want
everybody to go back to your country we
want to we're going to bring them back
uh sir uh we'd be honored to take MS-13
back we think they're lovely people sir
what seems to be the problem
immediately nobody has seen that before
25 years
night
night we would be honored
will be a great honor to bring back
MS-13 so they can kill our people
instead of yours
no it's terrible the people that run our
country are stupid people I will ask
every state I'd really like him to wind
this down because I'm very eager to hear
the questions people are going to ask by
the way our police are incredible our
firemen are incredible our police
are incredible and you know what they
know the bad ones they are they're in
the cities these cities these
democrat-run cities are going to hell
the whole world is watching but these
police are incredible they know the bad
ones but they don't want to lose their
pension they don't want to lose their
wife or their husband they don't want to
lose their home
so they're told to stand back but they
know every bad one they know everything
about it but I'll ask every state and
federal agency to identify every known
or suspected gang member in America and
every one of them that is here illegally
the police know every one of them will
pick them up and we'll send them back
home where they came from they'll be out
of here wow
really embarrassing and I will restore
my travel ban to keep radical Islamic
terrorists out of our country the travel
bill you saw what happened four years
four years we went four years you saw
that right
we were very tough in that we don't want
our buildings blown up we don't want to
have problems the Biden border crisis is
also a drug and Fentanyl crisis and a
human trafficking crisis like never
before mostly with women very sadly
mostly with women and it's uh now at the
numbers 12 times what it was three years
ago 12 times we had it really that we
were so tough on that what they do with
women and two women under my
Administration we reduce drug overdose
tests in New Hampshire by 18
18 we added 15 then we had at 18 and our
first lady worked very hard on that I
was muted clapping for 18 people not
exactly blown out of the water by that
and instead of being downed under Biden
as you know and your police environment
do an incredible job you have a real big
drug problem in New Hampshire incredible
almost worse than anybody relatively
that's what the governor should focus on
not running for president where is that
less than one percent
that's what he should focus on
but you have a real problem here and uh
I have to say you're a police in your
fireman I spend time with them and they
took me around one day and the job they
do on saving people a lot of the a lot
of the job they do is saving people that
have overdosed it's incredible the drug
cartels are Waging War in America and
it's time that America is going to wage
war that's what we're going to do we're
going to wage war on the cartels we're
being invaded our country is being
invaded and destroyed
thank you
for those wondering Donald Trump's been
speaking just over one hour sometimes
these speeches go as long as an hour and
40 minutes we will see
I was told you couldn't do it for it
would take three to four years to do it
and sure I don't think we could do it at
all I did it in three weeks I knocked
them out in three weeks
we have great generals I want not the
guys on television that that leave
Afghanistan before they take out our
equipment and our American citizens
where we lost 13 great people and nobody
ever says this where many soldiers were
just obliterated their arms their legs
their face obliterated because of people
that didn't know how to do their job and
why aren't these people fired why aren't
they fired
and I will ask Congress to pass
legislation ensuring the drug dealers
drug kingpins and human traffickers
received the death penalty because it's
the only way you're going to stop it
here we go
vicious crowd huh and I had a great time
and it was amazing amazing culture
frankly and I was with President XI
1.4 to 1.5 billion people I said you
have a drug problem no no no no no no
here we go no drug problem I said you
mean with all these people you don't
have a drug but no drug problem China
well what do you ascribe I think I knew
he said Swift trial
you know there's no games with it these
people you know when you meet with
President she doesn't say gee had the
Yankees do last night oh we have a
lovely day lovely day isn't it beautiful
out oh it's so beautiful Donald it's so
great he goes we will immediately
proceed to work
and you know what I love that I think
that's great there's no
okay
we will proceed
you meet him for two minutes we will
proceed there's no no games yeah how did
the Boston Red Sox do today
no they don't talk about that stuff they
talk about uh other things I mean why
the Chinese would care about American
baseball in general is kind of a
question I guess try the person and if
they're a drug dealer if they're selling
drugs Unfortunately they have the death
penalty and I don't think this country
is ready for it but they have no
drug problem whatsoever the big drug
problem they have is they make drugs and
send them into our country like Fentanyl
and even that I had him set except for
this rigged election he was set to make
that a criminal an absolute crime with a
death penalty for anybody making
fentanyl but once I left once this
horrible election took place they said
more over now than ever before he was
going to give the death penal that was
his deal with me he was going to give
the death penalty to anybody that
produced fentanyl can you believe that
in China it's uh too bad all these
people are dying all over we're being
invaded it's like a human Invasion to
combat the scourge of homelessness that
is plaguing democrat-run cities such as
Manchester I will use every possible
authority to get the homeless off the
streets immediately
that's so bad associate and you know you
have great hearts
especially the people of New Hampshire
and you know you don't want to even talk
about you don't want to say Jesus 15
people laying in front of my building
you know you feel badly about it but
you gotta you gotta do something for a
small fraction of what we spend in
Ukraine we could take every single
homeless veteran in America and take
care of them
likewise with all the money
we will save by ending Mass unskilled
migration that's what it is mass
unskilled you see where in California
now they're giving them Medical Care
education they're getting treated better
than our veterans are treated
and you know when they see that they all
come is Trump admitting that Republicans
don't really support the troops I
believe in California free and other
places free medical education the
classrooms you have people that can't
even speak English and they're sitting
all over the classroom it's killing our
country but we will have a huge dividend
to address the homeless crisis in our
own country we're going to save a
tremendous amount of money we're going
to take care of them we will get the
homeless into tent cities shelters rehab
and mental institutions and we'll get
them off the streets of our cities
and living like that is no good for them
the homeless and it's no good for the
people that have to make our cities
Great again you can't make your cities
great when you have thousands of people
laying all over the streets to uphold
our Second Amendment I will ask Congress
to put a bill on my desk delivering
National concealed carry reciprocity
give me a break
and I will immediately restore free
speech in America we've lost our Free
Speech but he's got its speech anymore
and we've lost we've lost our press
we've lost our media it's so sad what
happens to them they don't they don't
report it's not even what they report
they don't report they didn't report the
Biden stuff they knew about it they had
the 51 intelligence agents you saw that
where they said yes Russian
disinformation we don't have to report
it these are corrupt people this is this
and everybody knew that wasn't true
and we will take care of our amazing
veterans and we did it you know for four
years we had a 92 percent rating at the
VA at the vet
92 percent
you did a great job the highest rating
by far
by far that they've ever had on day one
I will sign a new executive order to cut
Federal funding for any school pushing
critical race Theory
transgender Insanity really do the teach
transgender line inappropriate racial
sexual or political content on our
children
I will also support parents rights can
you believe I have to say that
can you believe I'm saying I will
support parents Christ can you imagine
15 years ago saying I will support
parents right so people would look at
you they'd say this guy's crazy parents
rights of course who wouldn't support
that we still there are people that
helps them the parents have any rights
including the direct election of School
principles by the parents so you can get
people that you want terrible if any
principle is not getting the job done
the parents should be able to vote and
fire him get him out get somebody that
will get it back
and I will not give one penny to any
school that has a vaccine mandate or a
mass mandatory
people really like that that's the
Applause line of the night Standing
Ovation wow
crazy
looks like poorly timed conflicting
chance of four more years in USA crowd
very confused Governors would run their
states and generally they did those
mandates and they were disasters that a
lot of Republic a lot of them they
really didn't write Republican Governors
when you look at what happened and I
will tell you another thing that people
can't even believe I will keep men out
of women's sports whoa
and we will ban
that's a big issue that'll really
improve everybody's lives
Joe did you ever hear of anything like
that
[Applause]
during this young woman 19-year record
well I don't know what it is 200 and
somewhat pounds it's a lot it's a lot
for a man or for a woman to live but
it's a lot and this record stood woman's
record for for years 19 years or
something and uh
she got over the the barbell they put
like a little tiny ounce on one side
ounce on the other this thing was if you
beat it by an ounce you have the world
record
and she had up there and uh
should I do it uh
I'm gonna do it
she couldn't do it
then the guy came along who happens to
be a woman according to the laws of our
country
and he looked at it they said have you
lifted before not really
uh let's take a look he looks at it guys
he has the record by like 90 pounds or
something like it is so stupid it is so
unfair the swimmer you know about right
the swimmer she's a great swimmer great
great great swimmer she's going for the
world record she looked up and down she
sees young ladies that she grew up with
they're all great swimmers they've been
from the time they were born frankly
because that's the way it is they were
good from the time they were born Jack
Nicholas was a great golfer from the
first day he picked up a club that's the
way it goes right you know they were
great she looked up she sees her friend
she looks down then she looked to her
right and this is a huge person
look like Wilt Chamberlain
Wilt the silt he was
seven foot one now look like where the
wingspan he was built like this shoe she
was built I'm sorry
like this most perfect body I wish I had
a body like that I would have been
president 20 years ago if I had a this
is considered coming down like this
and
she looks he says wow oh whoa this is I
wonder
how she swims
and you know the young lady was very
seriously injured you know that right
wind burn because he went by her so fast
the wind was so great she got a bad bad
wind burn but she'll be okay now do you
think it does anybody really believe
what's going on in this country no
no I will sign a law prohibiting child
sexual mutilation
in all 50 states
these people are not really not
and this is what we must do
to save our country from destruction
2024 is the final battles uh if we don't
take it over we're not going to have a
country anymore that's it I want to be
positive I'm just telling you we're not
gonna if we allow them to cheat because
it's the only way they're going to win
the election if we allow them to cheat
again you're not going to have a country
if you put me back in the White House
the reign of corrupt Washington
establishment will be over in America
will be a this speech is scoring a plus
plus within cells in this election
we are going to complete the mission we
are going to finish what we started we
did so much we rebuilt our military so
much but we have things to finish stand
with me and together we will defeat the
globalists of marxist Communists and the
rhinos and we will also defeat the fake
news media because they're in on the ACT
we will evict Joe Biden from the White
House
and we will restore the American
Republic as the strongest priest and
most powerful Nation
the world has ever known we're going to
get ourselves back there and we're
getting very fast they know me very well
they're not looking forward to having
this happen
but they'll live with it actually we got
along with them pretty well there were
certain assets also you know other
countries need a strong America not just
us other countries need a strong America
the USA
is a mess our economy is crashing
inflation is out of control our banks
are failing Russia has joined with China
Saudi Arabia has joined with Iran China
Russia Iran North Korea formed together
as a menacing and destructive Coalition
our currency is collapsing and the
dollar will soon no longer be the world
standard can you believe this and that
will be our greatest defeat in over 200
years if we lose the dollar there's a
really good chance that we will
but it won't happen with me not even a
small chance just like Russia would
never have invaded Ukraine
for those just joining us or maybe who
joined an hour ago in the middle of
trump speech uh he said he would be
taking audience questions at the end of
the speech the speech seems to be
winding down I am interested one of the
funniest things is he just never answers
the questions
they would not have done near the
destruction to our country is Joe Biden
and the Biden Administration have done
but
now I say if you took the 10 worst
Presidents because I really believe that
if you took the 10 worst Presidents and
added them up they would not have done
to our nation what this man and what
this Administration has done and by the
way they're gonna after this speech
they're going to be coming after me big
time
[Music]
we are a failing Nation we are a nation
in Decline that's what's happening I
hate to say it I it makes you sick to
say it and now these radical left
lunatics want to interfere with our
elections by using law enforcement and
we can't let that happen with all of
this being said and with a very very
dark cloud hanging over our country
I have no doubt that we will together
win the presidential election of 2024
and make America great again we're going
to do it
[Music]
thank you God bless you everybody God
bless you
God bless you and now God bless me
because I'm going to take a couple of
questions okay
uh where are we gonna go with the
questions do we have a mic at some point
do we have a little mic oh go ahead
please yes yes ma'am hi I'm Elizabeth
Gerard thank you for the shout out early
I appreciate that
um one of the issues we are super super
passionate about at the New Hampshire
Federation of Republican women is
women's sports and keeping biological
men out of women's sports and out of
women's bathrooms right
um we've recently released a statement
calling on cowling out Chris Pappas and
Custer for voting against the protection
of women's and girls Sports act so how
do we ensure that women can compete on
an even playing field and feel safe when
it comes to this issue vote for Trump
that's how you do it okay you're gonna
have no problem
imagine getting a chance to ask a
presidential candidate former president
a question and that's the stupid
question you ask it's such a it's a good
statement and or a question but and we
will ban men
what's going on with that subject no no
you vote for Trump that's going to be
totally gone
okay
okay go ahead yes go ahead
yes sir Mr President uh thank you very
much Frank Dawson and thank you for the
phone call three years ago I remember
that yeah thank you very much you're
well the man thank you very much I would
like to ask you a question concerning
the military you promised the veterans
out there guarantee them that you will
make our military
yes I do out of office and you will
return and also make a promise to all
alarm enforcement all the legitimate law
enforcement they will
so I remember the call I don't know why
but I have a good memory but I remember
the call very much I appreciate uh the
love with that statement not just the
statement the answer is yes absolutely
we rebuilt our military that's the
finest equipment in the world you know
we had Jets who were 48 years old where
the grandfather was flying them some of
the bombers the grandfather was flying
them and now the grandson is flying them
now we're redoing our military we redid
a lot as you remember I made space force
and they tried to end it as soon as they
came into office and they had a Revolt
in the military we created space sports
that's the first time in 78 years since
the air force that something like that's
been done creating a new Branch so the
answer is yes 100 you will be satisfied
not only that the veterans are very
satisfied 92 but now in other words we
had an approval rating
the VA of 92 percent that's never
happened before that's a real job you
know we got approved sir do you promise
to make America great again if you win
yes I do did you couldn't fire because
of lots of reasons I won't blame Civil
Service I won't blame unions I won't
blame anyone you couldn't fire them and
we got that done and we also got it done
where you can go out and get your own
doctor and we pay because some of the
Veterans as you know were online for
weeks and months some of them became
terminally ill waiting to waiting to get
just a very simple procedure or or
prescription they'd have to wait four
five six seven weeks and we made it you
understand this those two things were
very important the ability we fired I
think 12 000 people there was sadists
there you go they wouldn't attack these
people in prime time I can tell you but
they were sadists they were thieves they
were there some very bad people we got
rid of them we we actually had that pass
in the legislature they've been trying
to do it for 48 years and then on the
other as you know that was a big deal if
you have to wait in line for any more
than 24 hours you have the right to go
out and get a doctor get yourself taken
care of and we pay the bill and that
worked out unbelievably well you know
that's true that's why they like this
but the answer is yes we'll take care of
it okay thank you good to see you
okay please
good afternoon Mr President I'm
Christine Peters also from the New
Hampshire Federation of Republican women
and two of the top three issues that
women are concerned about right now are
inflation and inflation and the economy
and um how do things like the
environmental social governance play
into
um all of the economic issues that are
facing women well they do and you know
you have these Fanatics the
environmental Fanatics Trump can't
answer that question well you know you
want clean water we want clean air
nobody wants dirty air and water and
other things so but you have to be
reasonable these people are crazy
they're putting windmills all over the
place they're going all over windmills
the birds that you want to see a bird
Cemetery go under the noise
and they're made in China just so you
know and causing a lot of problems very
expensive but I will say this we will
take care of this inflation by going and
drilling you know the sun in Canada they
have Con Edison in New York utility they
used have a son dig we must drill we
must we we must drill and we did some
job we had we had it down to below 1.87
for a period of time gasoline and what a
difference that made when they came in
and they closed everything down they got
rid of Anwar Anwar since Ronald Reagan
they've been trying to Ronald Reagan
couldn't do it Bush couldn't do it
nobody could do it I got it done the
biggest site probably in the world
Drilling in Alaska they ended it the
first day of the Biden Administration I
mean you think about it they ended it
the first day of the Biden
Administration a site that would have
been almost the size of Saudi Arabia may
be bigger and they ended it but we'll do
it again we can do it again we'll get it
done again when you reduce the price of
energy everything else is going to come
down and when everything else comes down
what we'll be able to do is get the
interest rates down and we're going to
get our country back because our country
the way it's going right now is going
into a depression we're going into a
depression like in nineteen 29 type
depression and we're not going to let
that there's no evidence we're going
into that we're going to get energy down
everything else when they held it back
the energy became so so oppressive so
expensive that everything went up and
you had inflation at a level that you
hadn't seen in 52 years and it's still
horrible but we're going to bring energy
down way down we're going to get the
interest rates down we're going to get
back to a great life we're going to
strengthen up our military and we're
going to be able to deal with China and
Russia and everybody and they're not
going to play with us they're not going
to play with us thank you
okay
go ahead yes go ahead
okay God bless you thank you very much
God bless you my name is Christine I'm
from Atkinson New Hampshire and engaging
with young voters is crucial here in New
Hampshire we have American first
Warriors like Caroline Levitt how do you
plan how do you plan to engage with Gen
Z voters well I think we're doing that
and I tell you what you would be shocked
like Charlie Kirk and others the job
that they do with their with their
youth it's a youth movement it really is
that's another movement you would be
shocked to see how popular we are on
college campuses much different than
what you read much different than what
you hear but you know one of the things
about having this horrible thing take
place where four years of uh we've lived
in four years of Hell in this country in
many ways in many many ways more ways
than you even know but one of the things
is
they have shown how bad they are and
we'll be able to do things now to get it
straightened out we have to make our
city safe again we have to clean up our
areas we have to get things going in
this country again they've shown how bad
things are the Voting is so dishonest
people see it people see it all you have
to do is just have a little common sense
and you see the level of dishonesty
because we want strong borders we want
great elections we want strong elections
we want great education and all of the
things that have happened in the last
four years have shown how bad these
policies are and it's actually in a
certain way going to make it much easier
for us okay one or two more go ahead do
you have anybody over there yes nose
please Mike let's go over here
hi my name is Tony hi Joe you're from
the cape all the way from Cape Cod nice
place
I just have a question on um election
Integrity so we're all here for a lack
of Integrity thank you that was going to
be my next question are we going to take
back 2020. I know we've got 22
but we need to still work on what
happened with 2020.
what happened is he lost how are we
gonna get 2020 oh my God these people
are insane you can do right now and and
there are a lot of people going you know
working very hard on 2020 because in
history you can't forget history we'll
take back 2020 after 2024 it'll be
interesting but there are many cases
going on right now you know that I think
you're involved in some of them but
there are many cases going on in
different states uh if you look at
Wisconsin what's she involved in
Wisconsin they were one crazy vote away
from turning over the election Trump
lost Wisconsin the political whack job
that voted the wrong way and other
judges on that panel just excoriated him
but you look at what's happened in some
of these states they they get it they
know what happened but you know what we
have to do never forget that I'm not one
of these so you have to forget it yet so
many people say Sir put it in the back
background put it you can't forget
because if you forget they're going to
do it again what we have to do is we
have to win because you know you're
talking about a verb he's Shifting the
message to we're not going to forget 20
20. but donate and vote for me in 24.
that we're gonna fix 2020 by voting for
me in 24. level at which they can't do
it and to be honest
we did so well last time I sort of
thought we swapped it but they used
covet to cheat among other things so
they use covet to cheat we're not going
to let that happen and we're not going
to hopefully have any of that but we
have to watch the most important thing
you can do is on Election night meaning
election period I'm sorry to say you
know France just had an election
recently 36 million votes all paper
ballot you had voter ID and it was same
day see it's same day voter ID all paper
ballot the election was over at 10
o'clock the numbers were cast everybody
went home congratulations there were
tears and there was a joy you know and
that's what we should do same day voting
because when you have voting that lasts
for 44 days and everybody's looking
around well I guess soon they're going
to get 20 20 back is the is the message
here yeah what are those things that are
moving in moving on
people have to have confidence in
elections people have to have confidence
I'm very confident Trump lost in 2020.
marriage that includes judges we have
judges that looked and they said oh boy
I'm I'm not turning this over they
didn't have courage they didn't have
courage to do what should have been done
but we can never forget that and it just
a lot of people are continue on we have
to win though now now we have one coming
up and we have to win like never before
we have to get more votes than anybody
ever got and we have to watch those
polling places stand over those you know
they threw our our people that were
watching our poll Watchers they call
them they had thugs in many cases those
were not actually poll Watchers they
were just people who showed up and said
I want to observe there were of course
poll Watchers
Democrats and Republicans even numbers
of each who were obviously allowed there
election we have to have courage and if
we don't have courage you're not going
to have a country I love your question I
love your question now we have to win
and we have to win bigger than ever
before and we'll get it all straightened
out okay we'll do one more how about one
more go ahead
now this is a bad question or if I don't
give a great answer I'll do another one
because you know you always Elton John
said encourse are very dangerous you do
a fantastic concert everyone's going
crazy then you do an encore of a song
it's good then you do another Encore and
the song doesn't work and you leave
everyone said what a rotten job but
you're never going to say that about
Trump right there you go let's go
president Trump my name is Brendan uh
and I would just like to know uh what is
your plan for dealing with
the growing threat of North Korea North
Korea has been a very a good example of
what intelligences I got along great
with Kim Jong-un we had a very tough
start I called him Little Rocket Man I
call them Rocket Man I call them lots of
things he called us and then one day I
got a phone call and they said you know
we want to get together and the Olympics
in South Korea was coming up nobody
bought it they weren't selling anything
and all of a sudden I got North Korea to
participate in the Olympics and the
things sold out like in two days it was
incredible what is it we're doing a
great job with North Korea uh we will be
able to deal with North Korea I don't
think this Administration will be able
to deal with North Korea okay one more
go ahead one more
yes ma'am president Trump I believe most
Americans can agree that the radical
less defund the police movement was
destructive it doesn't exist of course
it's still going on too by the way
absolutely what when when you are
president
what will be done to correct
do anything no police were defunded so
you don't have to do anything
interestingly enough first and um and
get them back on track so you're talking
to the right person we are taking care
of our police I did other than we want
to defund the FBI and the doj and the
Capitol Police were terrible on January
6th other than that they support the
police in some vague way we don't
understand and Obama didn't want to get
it out because he said it
good to give it I said immediately get
it out I gave billions and billions of
dollars you know what I'm talking about
all of this uh ex-military equipment it
was incredible and for safety including
trucks that were armor plated I gave it
all to the police we got it it was
sitting there drawing dust but very
valuable stuff we took care of our
police we are going to take care of our
police and we're going to make sure that
we support our police because our police
can solve the problems of our cities
instantaneously if you let them do their
job and we love our police so we love
our firemen and everybody else it does
but we have to support them and we can't
have them be afraid that if they use one
wrong word their life is ruined we can't
let that happen and you know which by
the way isn't what's happening to police
uh and you have bad apples every once in
a while something happens it shouldn't
happen and we have to understand things
like that can happen we have to support
our police these are Great American
Patriots they used to do a job now
they're not allowed to do the job we
have to allow especially in our cities
that are rotting and Decay we have to
let our police back we have to let them
do the job that only they can do they're
fantastic people and we are with them
and we're going to help fund them we're
not defunding we're going to fund our
police thank you great question well
ladies and gentlemen I want to thank you
it's an incredible this is an incredible
place this was a great day I enjoyed it
so much I want to thank Steve and all of
these incredible endorsers that's a
record-setting endorse but I want to
thank you all
God bless you all will be back God bless
you all
that's good
there you go
[Music]
wow
what a great speech huh
I really do Wonder like you go home from
this thing and you go what I really
liked it when Trump said the thing about
trans like
it's all really wild stuff
so uh you know this is what it's gonna
be like the next year I hate to break it
to you
debate scheduled to start in August
there's really not much more to say all
right everybody I really appreciate you
joining me we heard the same grievances
we've heard many many times
and uh really quite an unhinged speech
but the same speech he's been giving for
seven years if anybody's brain hurts
well fortunately it's over I appreciate
that everybody joined me and we'll have
our next stream very very soon make sure
you're subscribed on YouTube make sure
you're following on Twitch make sure
you've liked on Facebook you'll be
notified of future streams that way in a
very respectful and inoffensive way and
I'll see you very soon